let's not go back to the battle for
Bahamut in eastern Ukraine so the Wagner
mercenaries claim that they control the
city something the Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski denies will bring in
Jonah hall for more clarity on this
Jonah's joining us from Kiev so is there
anything more to indicate whether bakmut
has fallen into Russian hands or not
Jonah
well there isn't frankly a great deal
more clarity what we have are these
conflicting reports which is not unusual
along the front lines of the East where
very close quarters fighting is taking
place it's often hard to tell exactly
where the front lines are and frankly
they've been pretty static now for
months conflicting reports as you've
pointed out earlier on the one side from
yevgeni pregosian the head and founder
of the Wagner private military
contracted mercenary group essentially a
lot of his Fighters engaged in bakmut
saying that overnight and providing
video indeed uh claiming that his
Fighters had hoisted the Wagner and the
Russian flag above the administrative
headquarters in the eastern part of
bakmut uh the ukrainians pushed to the
western side of that town and that
therefore Russia legally held back moot
well the ukrainians certainly not
conceding anything like that a military
official saying that they are still
contesting and defending the eastern
part of the city that the situations
extremely tense president zelenski in
his address last night talked about hot
fighting inside bat milk so I think
we'll have to see how things progress in
the coming hours remember though that
Evgeni Prego has in the past declared
victory in bakmut only to be
subsequently proven wrong I how
important is the battle for bakmud for
both sides
uh well look I mean this is a pretty
sizable Town back moot former population
before the war 70 000 far fewer there
now of course but it has no notable
strategic value to either side in terms
of The Wider war and yet for months it's
been fiercely contested they've both
expended huge amounts of Manpower and
Munitions indeed both sides losing some
of their most their most experienced uh
fighters in the process so why so why go
so heavily after this place well because
simply it's taken on huge symbolic
significance to both sides for Russia it
is hoped that it would deliver momentum
in its goal of taking the whole of the
Donetsk region it's just inside the
regional border at one of four places
that Russia claimed to have annexed last
year despite not controlling any of them
for the Ukrainian side conversely it
takes on the huge significance of trying
to deny Russia the ability even of that
most basic of its War Ames so you know
whilst there is this huge expending of
uh military resources over bakmut it is
a symbolic and moral boosting victory
that will go to whoever prevails there
okay thank you so much Jonah Hall
reporting from Keith